the world loves to talk about cloud
technology this is not about technology
as for business transformation if I want
to engage to help you my questions are
what is the business problem that would
most transform your business what is the
agility dimension as its speed isn't
reached what is it that that you need to
accomplish your goal and then find our
cloud interest the beauty of IBM is that
we have a rich enough portfolio to help
almost any business in that space but
we've got to get them to think of it as
a business problem not a technology
problem everyone talks about cloud
services but enterprises need things
managed for them and for IBM that
opportunity of Managed Services is two
to five times the revenue of potential
of the infrastructure service that's
number one the second thing is really we
support IBM supports and our clients
need us to support a spectrum of cloud
choices some are pure cloud some are
cloud hosting some have only a small
element to cloud but depending on where
the client is on the workload and the
journey they need us to do all of that
and that's how we built our platform the
third thing is for that to to work and
have lasting and persistent value we
need to address the standards in the
interface and that's what our OpenStack
investments are about so that people can
start with one model do the work once
and if they need to move to another
deployment model they can do that with
open set none of our competitors cover
the range that we do amazon doesn't do
managed services other people do it for
them or for the clients HP does manage
services but only works in the local or
private cloud deployment model from a
client perspective being able to have a
supplier that they trust IBM able the
balance their needs no matter what the
deployment model and no matter where
your pure infrastructure or managed
services that's our differentiated value
for IBM to winning cloud we we have to
understand that we're solving business
problems so we have to engage with the
client to solve the problem that they
have
we have to make what we do consumable we
still struggle sometimes to make it easy
to use what we do and that's an offering
a product development thing and we must
move with speed we are in a new world
the world is moving whether we like it
or not we have to move with that thought
world it's really those two things here
the understanding the importance of
managed services to our clients
understanding the choice and the reason
that we have such a range of deployment
models for our clients and understanding
the role that OpenStack plays in
providing consistency for all of that